[Music]
kid cudi just paid tribute to two of pop
culture's biggest
icons yeah like i've been a fan of the
show and i was totally like i have to be
on board for his debut
musical guest appearance on saturday
night live the rapper celebrated
legendary rock star kurt cobain
by wearing this floral dress for his
performance of sad people
have i been wrong what does it mean
all what's the cobain connection
well the nirvana front man was known for
performing in dresses
including this very similar look which
fans posted to twitter after cuddy's
performance
on sunday cudi revealed the dress was
designed by virgil abloh
ceo of the fashion label off-white he
wrote quote
i told him i wanted to show love to kurt
with a floral prince sundress
and this man made a masterpiece cuddy's
snl appearance came one week
after the 27th anniversary of cobain's
death
[Music]
cuddy added that he's working on a
collection with off-white
and that the dress will be included
[Music]
and in another apparent nod to kurt
cobain cutty wore this green cardigan
for his performance of tequila shots
[Music]
fans on social media pointed out that it
looked very similar to this sweater
worn by cobain in his famous performance
on mtv's unplugged
[Music]
but the performance had a much more
prominent celebration for an
snl legend cuddy's t-shirt featured a
portrait of none other than chris farley
well because it is the great show that
it is of course there's expectations
before the show started cuddy actually
tweeted this behind the scenes photo
from the snl studio
um i banged my head jason sedakis
explained the backstory of this sign to
playboy in 2011.
he said quote there's a sign that says
watch your head over stage left of the
studio
and somebody wrote farley on the bottom
of it because i guess chris
farley used to always hit his head when
he ran off stage for a quick change
you